samy naceri a eu des hauts et des bas
dans sa vie maintenant c'est le on est
ravi pour lui alors c'est normal on va
lui faire une interview abendanon ne
bouge pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il a bougé ça me sert j'ai
bon à regarder mais j'ai compris un peu
tard qu'il fallait pas bouger on peut la
revoir à leur faire de toute façon voilà
doigt mais un flic qui lui disent
bien on va faire une interview à tanda
[Musique]
elle a encore parlé
c'est toujours la même mais mademoiselle
quotas
franchement
bien alors samy naceri interview à peine
d'arn c'est facile le plus le moins à ce
que vous préférez en vous
ma sincérité en amitié à sangles à vue
avec gilles de maistre c'est que ce que
vous détestez en veut bon comme on dire
quand on pardonne pas
on a du mal à pardonner aux gens quand
ils font
des erreurs avec moi à quoi je sais pas
comment on peut le départ donné
difficilement difficilement ouais vous
faire chier quoi
ce que vous préférez dans le cinéma se
retrouver devant une caméra bratton de
direction ouais
des fois c'est long un ouais c'est sûr
taxi un il ya 9 heures du matin qui
l'attendait toute la journée pour
conduire le taxi et à 16 heures quand on
l'enfilé la bagnole
il ya le fameux coup du viaduc qui dans
le film d'action le y avait un viaduc
qui était pas fini de construire il
compte du che comme une bête et il y
avait l'autre diefenthal je m'arrête à z
et les ouvrez la porte ses fruits avec
le pied le mec je me suis arrêté bien
avant quand même mais c'est vraiment le
truc le truc là où on voit que fred il
est pro quoi c'est que tout en ayant
peur ni voulais pas gâcher apprise il
voulait pas gâcher la scène donc il
ouvrait la porte il freinait avec ses
pieds il disait daniel quoi il faisait
tous amis ouais c'est ça get up ce que
vous détestez dans le cinéma mais
tu es beau tu es gentil était génial
c'est un peu dans tous les métiers quand
même et beaucoup dans le cinéma beaucoup
dans le cinéma le plus grand moment de
votre vie
la nomination aux césars ouais les
espoirs
puis à la naissance de julian aussi bien
sur le pire
le coupage de du film
ce qui vous fait le plus marrer dans la
vie mon frère ah oui oui je fais du
cinéma aussi ont ils écrit c'est un
comique n'est pas bon c'est un fou
furieux et un cimetière et le réveil
c'est un fou furieux qu'est ce qui vous
fait le moins rire le racisme
l'endroit où vous rêveriez d'être si
vous étiez pas avec laurent et moi et
nos amis téléspectateurs et notre public
ce soir avec marie dans un plumard moi
ce direct voilà est l'endroit où vous
voudriez surtout pas être
derrière les barreaux les mecs qui sont
enfermés en ce moment
ce qui vous aide à dormir le soir un bon
lexomil
ne s'est pas dangereux les xénons si ces
données si tu le prends avec modération
avec modération un c'est pas
mieux j'ai changé j'ai première la
solution alors oui c'est ça non je
connais une tonne l'adresse de raymond
barre il fut c'est l'opium a annoncé de
trompes raymond barre c'est pas l'opium
c'est quoi non parce que j'ai bien vu
comment ou via confondues c'est de
l'hélium qui la fumée
alors si vous êtes à dormir c'est un bon
examine avec modération et ce qui peut
vous empêcher de dormir mari aussi et
puis way et puis une mauvaise journée
c'est à dire que je me suis pris la tête
sur un tournage et puis je suis pas
content de moi et je me refais les
scènes 300 x 400 froid et puis marie à
la bombe dire ça y est c'est fini c'est
dans la boîte pour mort c'est fini
maintenant faut que tu remettre le
gouvernement ça ça m'empêche de dormir
marie est donc votre compagne et mon
amour voilà je le dis à nos amis
téléspectateurs ce qui vous excite le
plus chez une femme
qu'elle est en vie et kaki et caf à
celle qu'a pas envie ah
mais c'est bien sa
route alors
est-ce qui vous excite ce qui vous
excite le moins
une meuf
vulgaire qui tease et qui pour pour
m'intimider ou pour me sortent toutes
les cinq minutes des trucs comme on y
croise ivoire montchamp truc
juste pour parce que je viens un peu de
banlieue et tout ça et puis que elle
essaye de jouer cette carte là ça m'est
arrivé plusieurs fois ou vulgaire quoi
ce truc je joue un peu banlieues
populaires genre catherine deneuve 3
qu'est ce que vous avez de plus sexy en
vous a mis dans votre avis apprends
demandera aux filles ouais je crois que
c'est mes yeux et puis la psychiatrie
les yeux souriait les yeux la cicatrice
tous et dont
elle n'est pas sortie jamila brision un
excuser de moins sexy
rien ils disent avait bien quelque chose
de moins c'est que si je suis seul à
avoir là des trucs là mais non les
poignées d'amour ouais bon d'accord je
crois que je vous trouve très sexy merci
au cinéma c'est normal de faire quelques
bides
bon dernière question ce que vous ce que
vous préférez dans le sexe la chose qui
vous plaît le plus dans le sexe flirter
ouais ouais qu'est ce qui vous plaît le
mois
les trucs attaché à reims comme ça
vachement
écouté sa luge seront jamais des
aventures tous les cas
il faut essayer pour savoir enfin ce
avait d'ailleurs non non j'ai pas essayé
mais
vous plaît pas toutes les perversions un
peu comme ça il ya des perversions qui
sont qui sont on peut glisser et puis il
ya les pour essayer d'effacer truc jmh
un les anneaux dans les salles
des pinces à saint louis je vous fais
pas ça non je préfère le côté tu flirter
ça part en sucette à un moment donné tu
attrapes les cheveux
c'est trop chaud et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu